Now, I'd like to say a couple of words about training drills.
One of the most common forms of training drills is the multi-feed shuttle drill,...
...in which the coach holds a bunch of shuttles in one arm...
...and he uses the other arm to throw the shuttle across the net...
...and the student obviously has to try to retrieve it,...
...all the while making sure that the student returns...
...to the center of the court or his base after he hits it.
Jeffrey is gonna show you how to hit the shuttles.
One important thing to know is that the coach can vary the speed...
...at which he's throwing depending on the level of the student.
And he can also vary the direction in which he throws a shuttle.